[Applaudissements]
re et adorable merci
c'est vrai et stan que pour nous guide
elle
a une résonance particulière
il y a des années et des années que nous
nous retrouvons tous les ans ici dans
cette ambiance familiale
et
cette année
ces retrouvailles
avait un parfum particulier de
2,2 renaissance après de longue
parenthèse
et donc c'est pour nous
une si une un sens particulier
le sens particulier c'est en effet que
nous réussissions nous à nouveau à
confronter nos idées des convictions
avec vous monsieur le premier ministre
avec toi gens
que nous sommes extrêmement heureux
d'accueillir parce que nous sommes
extrêmement heureux de travailler
avec toi drire les masques j'étais en
train de confondre guérini et castex ce
ce qui n'est pas absolument
à mettre au crédit de mort
donc avec toi gens que nous sommes
heureux d'accueillir parce que nous
sommes heureux de travailler avec toi
dans une ambiance dont j'ai dit il y a
une minute qu'elle était marquée par
une communauté d'attitude et une
loyauté affectueuse
c'est pas des mots qu'on utilise
toujours en politique parce que c'est
pas des réalités qu'on rencontre
toujours en politique mais je voulais te
dire que c'était le cas
nous avons accueilli de la même manière
richard ferrand je veux dire que
dans
le moment de construction que nous avons
commencé
richard ferrand a été chaque semaine et
chaque jour actifs et attentif et que
nous étions heureux de nous trouver en
bretagne dans sa région avec lui
stan guérini a exprimé lui aussi à sa
manière cette communauté de pensée
d'ambition
et puis tous les autres marques et noms
patrick mignola jacqueline gourault
geneviève darrieussecq
sarah est la hérie
nathalie et limaces tous les députés au
féminin et au max et au masculin le
groupe et ses collaborateurs les
sénateurs les députés européens au
féminin et au masculin
nous plus nombreux au féminin qu'au
masculin je demande quand le quand le
note au passage
le parti démocrate européen avec sandro
comme si qui est l arme et tous ceux qui
en là encore au féminin beaucoup et au
masculin ont préparé installé accompagné
encadrer et sécuriser ces journées
puis il y avait bien entendu
dans l'atmosphère
quelque chose qui n'existait pas les
autres années parce que
sur chaque pan de mur et dans chaque
reflet des baies vitrées de guidel
il y avait pour beaucoup d'entre nous le
visage et la silhouette de marianne
[Applaudissements]
de l'élégance
de la volonté et du courage de maven de
marielle vivante
et pour nous ça compte beaucoup
peggy
que j'aime beaucoup aussi
peggy disait que dans l'histoire il y
avait des périodes et des époques
les périodes c'est candice passe pas
grand chose
qu'on a des événements qui sont des
événements à la dimension de nos vies
parfois microscopique on a l'impression
que le cours des choses ne changent pas
ou ne change guère
et puis il ya les époques et pas que ça
quelque chose de plus épiques se passe
de plus grandes choses il ya de plus
grand danger il ya de plus grands
risques et les époques accouche
généralement d'un monde nouveau
dans mon deux inédits et bien sans se
tromper on peut dire que nous voilà au
coeur
d'une époque et cela donne la dimension
de notre responsabilité
si on veut égrené ne serait ce que deux
événements majeurs le gilet jaune d'un
côté et
pis démis de l'autre
cette
la signification de ces deux événements
elle est pour moi absolument frappante
le premier
gilet jaune c'est un événement social et
culturel
inédit parce que d'habitude les révoltes
se passe aux marges de la société
est là pour la première fois
les gilet jaune n'était pas des français
des marges c'est pas des français
périphérique fait des français du coeur
de la société française enracinée
très souvent ayant des situations des
métiers des retraites qui on faisait des
désintégrer et tout d'un coup c'est
intégré ont constaté qu'ils étaient des
désintégrer qu'ils étaient en sécession
et en sécession assez profonde on le
retrouve encore dans les manifestations
d'aujourd'hui
contre les légitimités qui était jusqu
alors accepté sans la moindre discussion
et d'ailleurs si on voulait écrire
l'histoire des derniers siècles
alors c'est une mise en cause
progressive
des légitimités que tout le monde
accepte ça a commencé par la religion et
dieu c'est chez nous que la mise en
cause de cette légitimité a été
importante ça continue et par les
pouvoirs politiques on a l'habitude
ça s'est poursuivi par les pouvoirs
médiatiques et dieu sait que les
journalistes les regarde avec amitié ils
sont eux aussi au coeur de la
contestation et même cible est assez
fortement
et ça s'est achevé où ça a trouvé son
point culminant dans quelque chose qui
était absolument inattendu la dernière
légitimité qui était respecté par tout
le monde c'était la légitimité
scientifique et singulièrement la
légitimité médical et le fait que les
médecins se soit écharpe et en direct
sur toutes les scène pendant des mois et
des années ça fait que cette dernière
légitime et la légitimité la est
aujourd'hui mise en cause avec une
question très simple c'est qui es tu toi
pour me dire ce que je dois faire
2 quelle de quelle autorité
prétend tu me dicter ma conduite
et ceci crée un monde
d'abord qui nous permet de constater un
certain nombre de nos échecs des chèques
éducatif en est un j'ai consacré ma vie
à cette question
de l'échec de l'éducation mon premier
livre s'appelait la décennie des
malappris
parce que je me sentais bien dès cette
époque lointaine que on avait simplement
un problème de contenu et de
d'efficacité et de légitimité de la
transmission
[Musique]
échec de l'éducation échec de la
démocratie
de notre organisation démocratique
de l'imperfection de notre organisation
démocratique ou un très grand nombre de
français ne se sentent plus ne se
sentent plus représentés ou en tout cas
impliquée engagé
et enfin
dernier point une absence de sens
un devoir ou une injonction faite à ceux
qui en ont les responsabilités dans la
société
mais où nous amener vous qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensemble
c'est
là encore c'est pas pour citer mes
oeuvres complètes j'ai écrit il ya 25
ans livre qui s'appelait le droit au
sens
il ya des journalistes qui se moquer de
ce titre je prétends que c'était un
pitre juste que cette question-là la
responsabilité des gouvernants et de
donner un peuple des raisons de vivre
nous sommes à ce rendez vous aujourd'hui
mais nous ne pouvons plus donné à on
doit dire redonner au genre des raisons
de vivre
redonner à ceux qui nous ont fait
confiance à ceux qui nous entourent à ce
dont nous avons le destin entre les
mains cette certitude
que ensemble nous avons un chemin à
parcourir et ça se passe d'ailleurs pas
un hasard évidemment ça se fasse hooker
de crise planétaire
la pandémie c'est une crise planétaire
ça nous a montré au contraire de ce que
beaucoup de gens croyaient ou imaginer
que il n'y a pas de frontières pour le
virus comme il n'y a pas de frontières
pour l'atmosphère
que c'est que nous sommes
coresponsables
ou que nous vivions et où que nous
soyons
c'est pourquoi je je n'aime pas ceux qui
construisent des murs entre les peuples
n'ont pas seulement parce que je trouve
que ça trahit notre idéal commun mais
parce que ça ment sur la réalité il n'y
a pas de de frontières pour le virus il
n'y a pas de frontières pour le climat
est notre devoir est d'exercer une co
responsabilité sur ces sujets qui sont
des sujets planétaire et vitaux
[Applaudissements]
alors nous sommes responsables chacun
pour notre compte mais si nous nous
arrêtons à notre responsabilité nous
voyons rien du tout je prends un élément
de la crise climatique
pas un élément le l'élément fondamental
le
l'atmosphère de la terre
pèsent si je me trompe pas 5 millions de
milliards de tonnes d'atmosphère 5
millions de milliards de tonnes
et la france
elle relève de cette atmosphère
planétaire pour un millième
alors on a raison de se battre pour
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre chez
nous on a raison d'être fiers d'être
probablement aujourd'hui le pays le plus
vertueux ou presque le pays le plus
vertueux au monde pour les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en particulier
grâce au nucléaire on a raison d'en être
fiers
mais nous devons nous occuper d 999
autres millièmes en même temps
devons nous occuper de ce qui va se
passer en afrique
l'afrique c'est
100 fois plus important pour
l'atmosphère de la terre que ne l'est la
france
et la transition entre l'énergie
actuelle produite en afrique et
l'énergie future qui va être produite si
on passe par le charbon alors nos
efforts ne servent à rien
si nous ne sommes pas capables de
proposer dans le concert des peuples de
la planète
une stratégie commune pour
aller je vais simplifiée que ceux qui
étaient au charbon passe au gaz et que
ceux qui étaient au gaz passent à d
la du renouvelable
et du non émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre avec notre responsabilité
particulière pour la maîtrise des
technologies de production d'électricité
sans émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ce n'est pas capable de faire ça alors
on passe à côté et en mangeant on se
laisse abuser
parce que le sujet majeur et du partage
par les chinois par les indiens par
l'amérique du sud par l'afrique de cet
objectif commun et partagé
alors on a très bien fait dans les plans
successifs
de fixer à chaque peuple des obligations
mais je trouve qu'on est insuffisant
dans la réflexion partagée
et que 1 as obsédé à juste titre sur nos
stratégies nationales on passe à côté de
la stratégie planétaire qui est la seule
qui peut nous permettre de
de corriger la trajectoire
désastreuse qui nous conduit à avoir des
augmentations de température
catastrophique
et puis allez crise internationale
il ya cette immense
interrogations pendant longtemps nous
avons cru que la démocratie et l horizon
partagée de tous les peuples de la terre
ce avons cru que bon an mal an
chacun à sa place on l'a cru quand le
mur de berlin est tombé
chacun des peuples de la planète se
retrouverait avec les mêmes règles
démocratiques que les nôtres qui
pourrait choisir leurs dirigeants et
leurs modèles de société et puis
aujourd'hui cette question est
absolument
remise en cause cette question est
devenue
isolés nous sommes une une île où une
péninsule
démocratiques dans le monde
et quand on regarde ce qui se passe
ailleurs
alors on est saisi de cette inquiétude
est si peu à peu nous nous retrouvions
seuls les derniers défenseurs de cette
démocratie sur la planète
parce que ce qui se passe en chine tout
le monde là sous les yeux ce qui se
passe dans les crispations de l'inde
tout le monde là sous les yeux ce qui se
passe dans les grandes interrogations
sur la croissance la croissance chinoise
en particulier va avoir des
répercussions directes chez nous et
l'idée que on s'en remet au peuple pour
choisir le modèle de société
est une idée qui devient minoritaire sur
la planète nous avons donc une
responsabilité
particulière que bien d'autres n'ont pas
ou que d'autres ont éludé
qui nous place devant la question que
nous devons traiter aujourd'hui et cette
question pour moi elle est très simple
dans le paysage politique français et
européens
quel est notre devoir à nous
le paysage politique français tout le
monde le connaît c'est un paysage en
explosion permanente
sur tous les bancs comme on dit à
l'assemblée nationale
tous les mouvements politiques français
sont ou bien pris dans des rivalités
inexpiable qui son aplomb leclerc disons
le clairement des restes des des
rivalités de personnes
ce qui prouve d'ailleurs qu'aucune ne
s'impose vraiment parce que quand
quelqu'un s'impose vraiment on se
regroupe autour de lui
les partis politiques explose tout à
l'heure tu disais de droite et de gauche
aujourd'hui il ya trois droites
et 3 gauche
et les trois en effet sont en crise
interne si je ne sais pas si les
sondages sont vraies
mais je me mets à la place de ceux qui
ont cru au parti socialiste une partie
de leur existence
et quand je vois que la candidate qu'ils
ont choisie se retrouvent
dans des eaux d'intentions de vote qui
sont purement et simplement
dérisoire
j'imagine ce que ça doit représenter
comme comme inquiétudes comme sentiment
de n'avoir échoué quelque chose de tout
à fait essentiel ça doit d'ailleurs nous
servir de leçon
eh bien le défi est l'enjeu pour moi il
est très simple au moment où tous les
autres explose il faut que nous nous
reconstruisions et que nous rassemblions
et qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté sur ce
sujet
dans notre identité avec notre histoire
et avec nos racines
ça a été dit ce matin à cette tribune
par jacqueline en particulier et marque
aussi
ça fait 20 ans qu'on nous bassiner avec
l'idée que la droite et le centre
c'était la même chose
mais états de service
mon livret militaire
trouveront à qui veut l'entendre que je
n'ai jamais accepté cette idée parce que
comme tu l'as dit stan ce matin
moi je trouve qu'il ya rien de plus
stupide que la bipolarisation
rien de plus stupide que d'imaginer que
toutes les sensibilités doivent se
raccrocher à l'une ou à l'autre des deux
tentatives de simplification et de
domination comme si on voulait nous
expliquer que le monde ait
définitivement en blanc ou en noir et
qu'il faut être blanc qui faut être noir
et que si vous n'acceptez pas d'être
l'un ou l'autre vous êtes rayés de la
carte très souvent quand des
journalistes moody's bombe ce bayrou
vous êtes jeune homme du centre ok on a
compris
mais le centre c'est plus près de la
droite ou de la gauche
je leur disais excusez moi mais je vais
vous poser une question toute bête est
ce que vous connaissez les couleurs du
drapeau français
alors le les points d'interrogation se
lisait dans les pupilles jeudi dites moi
la couleur du drapeau français alors ils
disaient difficilement bon d'accord bleu
blanc rouge jeudi et le blanc c'est plus
près du bleu ou du rouge
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine hier les masques si j'ose
dire sont tombés définitivement les faux
semblants ont été effacés parce que nos
amis
rivaux
partenaires concurrents sais pas comment
on peut dire dans le jeu démocratique
français de la leyre ont répondu en fin
une fois pour toutes à la question et
ils ont dit ben parce que les mouvements
qui s'intitulait du centre encore
avait demandé à participer au jeu pas
nombreux
ils n'auraient pas changer le cours des
choses mais ils ont demandé à participer
au vote pour soutenir un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
et on leur a dit
j'allais dire poliment
moyennement poliment on leur a dit allez
vous faire voir
et un de leurs responsables a fait un
tweet en dix ans ils veulent participer
c'est très facile il adhère à l heure
est donc cette fiction que je déteste
ouvrez les guillemets de la droite et du
centre avec des traits d'union entre
chacun des mots de la droite et du
centre cette fiction elle est enfin
ruiné et nous pouvons enfin affirmé que
tout le monde est d'accord pour que nous
soyons nous mêmes
alors
je le dis d'autant plus je le dis
d'autant plus que je ne fais pas cela où
je ne soutiens pas cette thèse pour
soutenir notre identité je n'ai aucune
crainte ou notre identité je le fais
pour soutenir la vraie nature de la
démocratie qui est le pluralisme
pour moi on a parfaitement le droit
d'être à droite
on a parfaitement le droit d'être à
gauche et dans une des droites et dans
une des gauches plus nationalistes d'un
côté plus je ne sais pas plus plus
écologiste de l'eau y compris dans nos
rangs on a le droit d'être différent
d'être singulier d'être inédit
mais on n'a pas le droit de vouloir
soumettre les ans à la dictature des
autres
et donc
finalement c'était une bonne nouvelle
cette semaine cette clarification là
et nous alors nous nous modem nous en
marche et nous tous ceux qui se
reconnaîtront dans cette démarche
centrale
tous ceux qui comprendront
que nous construisons le pilier central
de la démocratie française
tous ceux qui comprendront que un bâton
a besoin de marée de quilles et que
c'est comme ça qu'ils
avancent et que c'est cela que nous
construisons tous ceux qui se
retrouveront dans ce projet alors ils
ont le devoir aux yeux des français de
sortir
des nuances excessive
de l'esprit de chapelle qui est dans la
nature même des organisations politiques
je sais très bien qu'on tient à sa
communauté de conviction à ces
communautés d'amitié en latin on disait
affectio societatis le le goût d'être
ensemble
c'est précieux c'est annie call regardez
c'est chaleureux affectueux
mais on a l'obligation d'entrer dans une
logique de dépassement et de vie en
commun de travail en commun de projets à
partager
et on allait en al'obligation de
simplifier cette affiliation aux yeux
des français
il faut qu'il y ait une identité commune
est simple pour que les gens là
comprennent
faut qu'il y est
allez un nom qui nous réunit tous on
verra ce qu'on partage
et après chacun se situera où ils
préfèrent y aura des débats d'idées à
l'intérieur de cette nouvelle entité
mais je voudrais appeler votre attention
sur ce sujet parce qu'il est à mon sens
très importante et comme toi formulée
stan des exigences je voudrais leur en
formuler quelques unes à mon tour
la première exigence
c'est qu'on ne transforme plus les
débats d'idées en combat pour le pouvoir
à l'intérieur
de cette entité commune
beaucoup observé les constructions du
même ordre de quoi le parti socialiste
est il mort
c'était une formidable entreprise
le parti d'epinay et la conquête du
pouvoir
et les grandes figures
françois mitterrand jacques delors
michel rocard d'une formidable
entreprise
mais il avait dès le premier moment
introduit le virus dans le système et le
virus s'était que
l'émotion qui était censé traduire des
sensibilités en réalité c'était des
entreprises de prise du pouvoir en
interne et moi je propose que nous ayons
comme règle de séparer les débats
d'idées
et les combats de pouvoir que ça ne soit
plus
une confusion entre l'un et l'autre on a
le droit
d'avoir des sensibilités de le devoir
d'avoir des sensibilités différentes
mais ça n'est pas la prise du pouvoir
qui est en jeu ça c'est la première
condition la deuxième condition que je
souhaite c'est que les français puissent
adhérer directement à ce nouveau
mouvement sans passer par l'une par
l'autre des chapelles
après auprès d'eux
chacun pourra défendre sa sensibilité
mais on peut pas leur demander d'entrer
dans le labyrinthe de nos histoires
conjuguer
confluentes
et amicale il faut que faut qu'on puisse
adhérer à un vaste ensemble je sais très
bien pourquoi les français n'adhèrent
plus aux partis politiques ils adhèrent
plus aux partis politiques pour deux
raisons principales la première c'est
qu'ils ne veulent pas être inféodé
ils veulent pas que qu'on prenne le
contrôle de leur volonté
de 2 peu de beaucoup ils veulent
conserver leur liberté ils ont
l'impression que quelques fois où
souvent quand ils adhèrent à un parti
politique ils perdent une partie de leur
liberté nous nous voulons les rencontres
et les travailler avec eux sans
confisquer leur liberté une seule
seconde c'est le premier point le
deuxième point ils veulent pas des
guerres de chapelles
qu'ils en ont marre qu'on passe leur
temps
sous couvert de grandes idées
à défendre des intérêts et des intérêts
personnels souvent
c'est du tpm j'ai un tout pour ma
gouverne si j'ose dire
et donc j'ai donc cette voie là c'est
eux c'est ce qu'ils ne se qu'ils ne
veulent pas c'est ce qu'ils ne veulent
plus alors je propose qu'on leur
fournisse le chemin pour échapper à ces
deux fatalités là
et donc ce ce rassemblement de ce grand
courant de la démocratie française
il est pour moi vital
comment le définir moi j'utilise jamais
le mot de centristes
je le je le respecte
je respecte et j'aime bien ce qui met
d'abord c'est pas un joli mot parce que
il rime
avec un adjectif qui ne correspond
absolument pas à notre nature profonde
nous on est plutôt joyeux et donc est
gay vous me suivez parce que j'ai
l'impression ce que j'ai l'impression
j'ai eu l'impression d'un grand moment
de solitude dans quai
et donc je me trouve le mot pas très
joli et puis surtout c'est une
définition géographique
alors que notre définition a non elle
est plus vitale elle fait appel à la
sève de l'engagement politique c'est
pourquoi ce que j'aime
j'aime deux choses deux idées la
première idée que j'aime c'est une idée
incroyable en fait perpétuellement à
contre-courant
perpétuellement rebelles
c'est l'idée de démocratie
qui veut dire que
les sujets
les femmes et les hommes qui composent
une société deviennent des citoyens
j'aimais bien frédéric en pologne le
l'idée initiale de la plate forme
civique qui avait quelque chose là
dedans qui faisait que
chacun était invité à se hisser
au niveau de citoyens c'est à dire au
niveau de responsable quelle que soit sa
situation
quelle que soit sa situation matérielle
sa situation culturelle et sociale
il devient il se sent il se comporte
comme personnellement personnellement
responsable du destin commun de la
communauté à laquelle il appartient la
démocratie c'est ça on avait ça ce matin
affiché sur le rap au c'était le c'était
le mot de marc sangnier
l'organisation sociale qui porte à son
plus haut la conscience et la
responsabilité des citoyens
la conscience
formation information et la
responsabilité des citoyens et là nous
avons
un idéal donc j'aime le mot de
démocratie
et j'aime le mot république
j'aime les mots république parce que la
république c'est
une
idéale un projet
qui est que
chacun a droit à être conduit
par la liberté
par l'égalité
jusqu'à la fraternité et vous voyez
liberté égalité fraternité en réalité
c'est un escalier c'est une échelle de
jacob
parce que la fraternité c'est pas
naturel parmi les êtres humains
la fraternité
chez les êtres humains c'est plus
souvent la loi de la jungle la loi du
plus fort ceux qui veulent imposer leur
loi aux autres ou qui acceptent de subir
la loi des autres mais la fraternité
ça permet de dépasser tout ça et je
trouve moi donc les mots de démocratie
et les mots de république sont
complémentaires
si je si je pouvais dire je dirais que
la démocratie et soeurs de la république
ou la république et soeurs de la
démocratie et que donc là nous avons une
définition en interne de la sève de ce
que nous de ce que nous portons
après tout ça repose sur une philosophie
et il faut des mots simples ou en tout
cas dont la signification des chapes a
personne pour incarner ce que nous
sommes nous avons une philosophie
commune cette philosophie c'est
l'humanisme
c'est
quand on sait ça quand on sait
quand on adhère à cette idée que
erasme
a dit une fois pour toutes il ya bien
des siècles il a dit on ne naît pas
homme
on le devient
et simone de beauvoir après simone de
beauvoir affaires a repris on ne naît
pas femme on le devient ça veut dire que
le
la pleine conscience
de sa responsabilité comme frères
humains
le
l'éducation de du socle qui va faire que
vous pouvez comprendre le monde dans
lequel vous êtes et que vous pouvez
comprendre l'autre
dans sa différence dans ces difficultés
dans sa singularité et non pas le
rejeter et le bannir perpétuellement
mais
partager quelque chose avec lui être
engagé dans une compréhension mutuelle
ça c'est la vraie laïcité
la laïcité n'est pas une exclusion à mes
yeux
résister c'est une compréhension c'est
l'affirmation que la différence est
acceptée et qu'on peut travailler
à construire un destin commun même si on
n'est pas les mêmes c'est pourquoi je
suis je suis sûr comme beaucoup d'entre
vous
très choqué
de ce qu'on entend comme c'est pas des
idées c'est des obsessions qui sont ces
temps ci portait dans le débat politique
français notamment l'obsession sur
l'identité et sur les prénoms ça a l'air
de rien salaire d'un gag c'est par gagne
quelque chose de profond il ya quelqu'un
qui a fait ça au 20e siècle
c'est le maréchal mobutu
mobutu dans le pays qui l'avait nommé à
l'époque le zaïre
mobutu il a pris une loi pour interdire
les prénoms qui n'étaient pas des
prénoms africains savaient
au zaïre à cette époque
il y avait plus de 60% de la population
qui était chrétienne catholique et donc
il y avait des prénoms comme ça et
mobutu lui même son prénom c'était
joseph
avant de se faire appeler mobutu sese
seko
c'était joseph et il a fait une grande
déclaration pour dire il n'est pas
possible que l'africain porte un prénom
juif
et il a pris une loi pour interdire ces
prénoms il a dit ça n'est pas possible
qu'une femme africaine s'appelle chantal
ou marie
les le les vidéos existent eh bien je
n'ai pas envie que la loi de mobutu
deviennent d'une manière ou d'une autre
une loi ou une proposition pour la
france
[Applaudissements]
vous vous rendez compte je pense
beaucoup aux soldats ces jours ci avec
la mort de ce jeune sous-officier qui
était héroïque je crois qu'on peut le
dire et qui est tombé dans une embuscade
geneviève et et vous monsieur le premier
ministre
vous savez le nombre de soldats que nous
avons dans les rangs de notre armée qui
portent des prénoms
aussi divers que leur origine ne sont
que leur culture leçon que la religion
de leurs parents lait et on va dire
qu'ils ne sont pas français on va les
obliger à changer de prénom mais dans
quel monde veut on nous faire vivre
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya des paris derrière tout ça
il ya des paris et des programmes parce
que le pari c'est que
avec ses videla qui sont des idées je
sais exigeante qui ne viennent pas
naturellement je répète le ce qui vient
naturellement c'est la détestation du
voisin
qui c'est celui là d'où il vient et
celle là l'est pas de chez nous
croyez moi on a vécu ça dans les
villages des pyrénées
je connais
dans les générations plus anciennes des
gens qui étaient du village voisin on
n'a jamais considéré comme étant des des
autochtones
il y avait 800 m n'est ce pas jean et
avait 800 mètres entre les entre les
villages n'étaient pas de là
et donc
j'aime cette idée que
qu'on va s'entraîner les uns les autres
à comprendre mieux le voisin
pas à abandonner ce que nous sommes
a abandonné notre identité
ni nos manières de vivre
ni les principes qui sont les nôtres
et à être absolument clair sur ce sujet
de
j'étais très heureuse ces jours-ci yeux
alors je vous confie un de ces bonnes
âmes de il ya un très grand sociologue
qui s'appelle éric morin
qui vient d'éditer un livre qui
s'appelle trois leçons sur l'école
républicaine il a conduit une enquête de
sociologues sur la décision que j'ai
prise en 1981 14 ou 15 2
d'interdire le voile à l'école
et il dit ne vous trompez pas pardon de
le citer 1
il dit ne vous trompez pas c'est pas la
loi qu'on a voté en 2004 qui a changé
les choses c'est la circulaire que
françois bayrou avait fait en une seule
année une seule année le résultat des
filles au baccalauréat des filles
d'origine des quartiers au baccalauréat
a bondi de moins de 50 % à plus de 65%
pas les garçons
sont restés au même score mais les
filles
je sais pas si vous représentez ce que
ça veut dire de passer de deux moins de
la moitié a plus des deux tiers de
résultats au baccalauréat en une seule
année il explique sa part le sentiment
de libération qu'elles ont ressenti
parce que simplement un gouvernement
avait eu je passe il faut dire le
courage en tout cas avait choisi
d'imposer quelque chose qui était
émancipateur une règle qui était
émancipatrice
[Applaudissements]
et je voudrais finir sur une idée pour
respecter pour une fois j'ai entendu
pour une fois dans la salle
le temps de parole qui était qui était
le mien je voudrais défendre devant vous
une idée qui est en même temps
une volonté pour l'avenir est là
l'énoncé
de d'un impératif pour nous nous vivons
dans un débat politique dans lequel
on chante les louanges de la radicalité
des radicalités et on a des radicalités
opposées les unes aux autres qui se
démolissent le portel
allègrement et on applaudit et bien moi
je pense qu'il y a dans la radicalité
sans qu'il y ait jamais eu aucune
exception historique je me tourne vers
jean louis bourlanges
je ne connais pas de radicalité qui
n'est mal fini
partout dans le monde
c'est ce type de révolution du ti vise à
quelque chose de simple s'est imposée
aux entre
la loi qu'on estime nécessaire
ce qui pour moi est le contraire de
l'idéal démocratique
l'idéal démocratique c'est pas d'imposer
aux autres sa loi c'est de permettre que
les convictions vivre ensemble selon des
règles harmonieuse et qui réponde aux
impératifs de chacun
la rade et les radicalité on sait
comment ça finit dans quel massacre
mobutu le une fois qu'il a eue fait ça
un jour il a pendu 500 personnes dont
les convictions religieuses ne lui
plaisait pas sur la place publique
et je veux pas parler des autres
révolutions et des massacres qu'elles
ont entraînés
je pense qu'on a le devoir
de défendre devant nos concitoyens une
idée simple l'avenir ne doit pas être
radicalité les unes aux autres l'avenir
doit être à léquilibre aux équilibres
que nous avons à construire un
gouvernant c'est quelqu'un qui recherche
l'équilibré de la société de la
communauté à laquelle il appartient et
quand on va vivre les mois qui viennent
avec la campagne électorale les
campagnes électorales successives mais
d'abord la campagne électorale
présidentielle
alors j'invite à ce qu'on garde ce
critère de réflexion
qui nous invite à des radicalités qui un
jour finiront en affrontement inexpiable
qui nous invite au contraire à nous
rassembler qui nous invite à dépasser
les les préférences de l'instant pour
construire un pays commun une une
communauté de citoyens et une communauté
nationale
et je veux le dire simplement
quand je regarde aujourd'hui la
situation de la france je vois un
président de la république
me suis pas toujours entendus avec les
présidents de la républiques successives
peux pas me faire des procès de
complaisance
réitéré mais je vois un président de la
république qui est à hauteur de
l'histoire et je témoigne et tous ceux
qui sont ce qu'ils ont l'occasion de le
rencontrer peuvent attester avec moi que
non seulement il est à la hauteur de
l'histoire mais il est vraiment est en
réalité à hauteur d'hommes de femmes et
d'hommes d'enfants et d'adultes et de
personnes plus âgées
il y a en lui quelque chose d'une
empathie qui s'est pas révélée jusqu'à
maintenant trop souvent parce que ça
passe pas les grandes télévisions mais
nous le savons bien il ya quelque chose
de
de fraternelle dans le regard qu'il
porte sur ceux qui lui parle et je
trouve que avoir un président de la
république à hauteur d'homme
et un président de la république à
hauteur de l'histoire ça vaut la peine
de s'engager et de s'engager pour ce
combat l'un
pas pour des combats d'ego
est pour quelque chose qui va faire pour
notre pays ou qui va préparer pour notre
avenir pour notre pays le seul avenir
possible
c'est un avenir courageux et fraternelle
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]